Here's another way to visualize the
relationship between these different attributes that
I mentioned of performance, extensibility and
protection or safety. A DOS-like structure that
does not pay attention to safety or protection, needs the two attributes
of performance and extensibility. A micro
kernel based approach achieves protection and extensibility,
but may have issues with respect
to performance. A monolithic structure may yield
good performance, has protection. But, it is not easily extensible. Now what do
we want? Of course we want all three of these characteristics in an operating
system structure. But can we have all of these three characteristics in
an operating system? In other words, what we would like the operating system
structure to be such. That, we get to this, center
of the triangle that caters to all three attributes. Performance,
Extensibility, and Protection. And the research ideas that we will
study in this course module. Is, looking at ways
to get to the center of the triangle so that all three attributes
can be present in the structure of the operating system. We will resume the
course module with research approaches that have been proposed than that we will
cover in this course module that help us get to the middle of the triangle.